we recreated every single challenge from
squid game and minecraft and whoever won
squid games got 45.6 billion won which
is why the winner of our challenge here
gets 45.6 grand this first challenge is
red light green light and when i press
this button the entire board turns red
and no one can move if someone moves
even just a centimeter
they die we have an eight minute timer
that's counting down let's see if anyone
will walk on the red
don't walk on it they're all dying
go
up red light
whoa
oh god this is exhilarating we got seven
and a half minutes i'm gonna wait i'm
not changing until someone gets out i
don't want to get out how are you carl
i'm shaking
the timer
oh somebody got out he's always going
out so we go okay there you go
go go go
oh
oh my gosh someone died dream i'm behind
you oh so you guys can turn i don't want
to find out i'm not risking it
go go go go
oh oh that was a quick one
oh we got a lot of people
he's crazy
nope seriously stop jimmy stop this guy
moved me
oh you almost got me i thought that
would work these two people haven't even
left the start line yet what are you
doing why do you think this guy hasn't
started yet
jimmy we got like 3 30 left we need to
go we need to go we only have three
minutes jimmy
all right let's see if i can get him out
oh no okay this guy finished but he's
too afraid to move because he's on the
finish line
oh my gosh
oh my god dude we got a minute and 40
seconds left what are they worried about
i don't think i'm gonna make it i'm
worried
oh almost through the game jimmy please
i don't have a lot of time
oh my gosh
[Music]
i win i did it
jimmy let us go
i made it i made it
tommy come on you can make it
yo that guy died on the finish line i'm
behind i'm behind dream i'm behind dream
as well
oh my gosh that was risky that was risky
all right one minute remains chris isn't
even moving
okay 20 seconds look how close they are
come on chris i'm not over yet
yes yes
yes can he make it can he make it come
on run
we started with 150 people and now we're
down to 110 for this next challenge
every player has been assigned to a
random team each team has a color and a
shape they must make last team to create
their shape is eliminated why did i get
umbrella let's go circle baby
the challenge has begun go go go go go
go go go now watch this i can remove the
blocks from the bridge
oh wait they fold they fall no
wait i just fell what yes
if you died but your team doesn't lose
you come back for the next challenge
the only one over tommy get the wall go
go get one get walk get it get wall get
well get as much wool as you can grab it
all let's go all right let's go back
tommy go trailer go go trailer go yes i
made it i made it i made it tommy tommy
get this guy
they are all building whoever builds her
shape last loses one two three four
here and then there okay is blue doing
okay i can't see it blue's doing great
they're actually almost done i'm out i'm
out i'm out this is not right what are
they doing what are the green green is
so dumb oh this is neck and neck oh boy
yellow's really fumbling the bag over
here tommy get your crap together this
is so hard
come on green come on green place the
block here place the block here
we did it right we did it all right
green team is the first to pass yeah
let's go all right comes down to these
three we're good on that side
why is this person destroying my stuff
not the exact shape
y'all red team is now done yellow versus
blue who will win this one's destroy
this are we done the middle of it don't
fill it in
wait that's good that's it that's it
wait we've done it blew us first what
yeah let's go
oh wait carl you on yellow team and
tommy at least i don't have to get
spoilers now for the next game we are
playing tug of war there are two teams
standing on a single row of blocks the
teams have to fight head to head and
avoid getting knocked off the platform
if you fall off but your team ends up
winning you come back to life all right
chandler we're on the same team let's go
go blue go we got this come on red team
start
go right deep
oh infiltrate infiltrate
oh that blue guy infiltrated
push up push up push up blue is up by so
much make sure you control the middle
should we control the middle wait
they're punching oh my team's hitting me
oh wait they just punched each other off
no i fell oh no oh no red's coming red's
coming right it's coming what's up boys
push up chris's steward die chris wait
should i kamikaze should i kamikaze go
for it go for it go for it i'm coming
[Music]
i'm coming to you oh
my dream oh it's actually coming down to
the wire oh there's three blue there's
two red
three v two oh oh oh and blue remain
standing
yeah
let's go
all red team players are officially
gonna be kicked blue players that died
will be brought to life next game so
this next challenge i gave each player
10 wool paired them up with someone
random except for dream because we had
an odd number let's go
and let them compete in whatever game
they agreed to for the wool sapnap and
his partner tried to see who could throw
their block the furthest clearly snap
nap one it was actually an honor to meet
you guys
if i win can i give him money chandler
played a game of guessing odds and evens
and he won
oh my gosh i'm so sorry and here's
everyone else that got eliminated
[Music]
there are 13 people left now on to the
next game in this game there are rows of
glass
left glass or right glass one glass
panel is safe to jump on and the other
shatters when you touch it causing you
to die there's no way to tell the
difference and once a panel is broken it
stays broken and the remaining players
get to use that intel going forward and
now that you guys are arranged
alphabetically server start the
countdown i'm screwed go i'll push you
off wait wait wait wait wait
oh my gosh
oh my god all right chandler good luck
all right dream come on it's safe and in
case you guys are wondering pvp is on
stay back oh damn stop it hey why are
you guys punching each other don't punch
me why are they punching me off taylor
we have five minutes go to the right
oh let's go
yes yes chandler yes somebody get their
butt out here
don't push me shout out don't punch me
don't punch me all right all right i
won't
four minutes to remain chandler go
you're gonna screw people out of money
oh
yeah
i'm so good chandler keep your good luck
streak going go go go guys we have three
minutes and 40 seconds
wait what am i doing no
no
no
why didn't you do that dream dream's an
idiot all right chandler go there's no
way
dude i'm so good you're halfway there
oh
wait taylor how are you doing this this
is improbable go for it go forward
no no
oh
no
this lock streak ran out i died one
minute and 30 seconds remain you still
have seven jumps go elf go for it got
more out
oh
oh
okay four jumps left
no it's an election left
minute 15 to make three jumps go arcade
go go arcane go oh geez oh geez remember
if you do not make it cross i keep my
money and you guys win nothing
oh no
nice two jumps remain four of you go
forward go forward go forward no you go
no i'm not going i'm not going i don't
want to go you go how about one of these
people jump they haven't jumped once
40 seconds oh my god
oh
one more jump 20 seconds just do it jump
jump on jump jump
oh my god oh my gosh one of you is
walked away with forty five thousand six
hundred dollars let's proceed for the
final challenge we have squid game but i
have no idea how to play this game so
we're just gonna do a bare bones fight
to the death starting now
yeah squeaky yes we can go go wiki no no
no stay away from me stop now come here
last standing wins 45.6 grand ricky i'll
give you money i think you guys should
double team snap-nap he's already rich
dream pays your right you're rich winky
you are a traitor all right this is
taking too long server give them wooden
swords
winky let's team we'll have a fair 1v1
after minky we should kill snapchat he's
rich we can't do that
dude
[Music]
has more help than both you
combined you're dead
stop naps you just won 45
600 what do you have to say
91012 two i wanna give them ten thousand
dollars what about these two people you
just slaughtered i'll give them five
thousand dollars each subscribe